[Musique]
le montana l'état du grand ciel une
expression qui prend toute sa
signification dans un coin de pays si
vierge du moins en apparence
car dans cette immensité si silencieuses
se cache un des pires pollueurs de la
planète et en plus il est presque
invisible c'est le méthane qui
s'échappent de ses puits de gaz et de
pétrole a abandonné il ya parfois
quelques décennies
comme celui ci vous l'envoie encore l'or
noir qui bouillonne non loin de la
surface ce qui génère des quantités
astronomiques de gaz à effet de serre
des puits comme celui là il y en a plus
de trois millions aux états unis
les solutions se trouve peut-être dans
cette petite ville du nord de l'état
cherbi à 40 minutes au sud de la
frontière canadienne c'est là que s'est
installée koltis chaque celui qui a déjà
travaillé dans l'industrie pétrolière
s'est trouvé une mission il veut boucher
tous les puits les uns après les autres
et il se dépêche pour enfermer dix
autres d'ici la fin de la saison
[Musique]
ainsi il sillonne l'état pour surveiller
et évaluer le niveau de pollution
générée par ces milliers depuis devenus
orphelins et extrême pollueurs une quête
qui l'a entamée il ya presque deux ans
lorsqu'il a croisé ce tas de bois et de
ferraille
prochaine
depuis il s'entête à trouver des parents
adoptifs pour régler le problème de ces
orphelins pollueurs
[Musique]
dans bien des états comme le montana au
fil du temps la course à l'or noir s'est
ralentie des puits de pétrole ont vite
fait de s'épuiser petit à petit et
finalement ont été abandonnés
alors avec quelques travailleurs d'un
secteur en difficulté que chuck a
assemblé une équipe pour tenter de
régler le problème
ici ils enfoncent des conduites jusqu'à
près de 500 mètres de profondeur afin de
toucher le fond du puits de pétrole
fermé en puits n'est pas insurmontable
cela peut se faire en deux jours et le
résultat est tangible
boucher un puits comme celui ci coûte
environ 30 mille dollars mais qui
finance une telle opération
la fondation wheldon dit il n'a pas
accepté un seul dollar des contribuables
et il gère l'organisme sans but lucratif
presque comme bénévole alors qu'ils
payent la facture dans le cas de ce
puits par exemple la réponse se trouve
en fait à plus de 8000 kilomètres au
japon où fuyuki fujiwara un gestionnaire
de fonds de placement de 52 ans a décidé
de sortir son chéquier et sow
[Musique]
quelques semaines l'équipe de curtis
choc à colmater cette autre puis il n'ya
plus d'émissions métal grâce à un autre
généreux donateurs qui a fait ça par
action
au grand plaisir de sam stout le fermier
propriétaire de cette parcelle sur
laquelle se trouve pas moins de 16 puits
de pétrole abandonner tout profit pour
lui qui n'a pas déboursé un seul dollars
pour régler son problème
mais il n'ya pas que les particuliers
qui participent à ces fermetures depuis
pollueurs en pennsylvanie c'est la
compagnie énergétique seneca resort qui
a financé la fermeture de ce puits il y
à un mois un puits qui ne lui
appartenaient même pas
là aussi le ciment qui déborde est une
bonne nouvelle pour le propriétaire du
terrain mais aussi pour l'état de la
pennsylvanie
[Musique]
rédemption sur le tard pour les uns
prise de conscience environnementale
pour les autres la solution à ces
millions depuis pollueurs prendra du
temps curtis chuck et réaliste il ne
pourra pas y arriver tout seul il espère
malgré tout fermer un millier depuis
l'an prochain
prochaine étape la louisiane et
l'oklahoma avec des projets en gestation
au canada et en amérique du sud curti
choc va continuer de traquer le méthane
créant même avec son équipe grandissante
une nouvelle expertise dans le domaine
des mesures et de la détection pour
l'instant une bonne douzaine de puits
ont été colmatées
plus de trois millions d'autres [ __ ] a
fermé un seul à la fois
[Musique]